after Lenin came down with the case of
the Dead it wasn't long until Joseph
Stalin took over as the Undisputed
leader of the USSR as many of you will
know Lenin was not a fan of Stalin and
openly didn't want him to succeed and
yet Stalin won out in 1924 and a few
short years later the Soviet Union was
under his absolute control which raises
the question why why did Stalin take
over the USSR instead of somebody like
Trotsky so as of Lenin's death the
politburo consisted of these seven men
all of whom had some chance of
succeeding Lenin publicly the new policy
going forward was that the USSR would be
led by a committee of equals who would
vote on policy privately scheming Stalin
was quick to act and along with Lenin's
Deputy Lev kamenev in a man called
Gregory zenoviev who was in charge of
commenter and the three formed an
alliance this Alliance was called the
Troika which had the sole purpose of
blocking Leon Trotsky from Power why
well the primary reason was that there
were major policy disagreements between
them as a result of economic troubles
during the Russian Civil War Lenin had
implemented what was called the New
Economic Policy this allowed for things
like the private sale of goods for
profit into the new Communist economy
which Trotsky had opposed Trotsky was
very popular with the general population
in the USSR and this popularity meant
that he could rally support especially
from the military which for the other
members of the Pollock Bureau could
cause problems as such with a gentle
push from Stalin's anovie Evan kamenev
publicly denounced Trotsky as being an
enemy of Lenin's Vision over the next
year and a half both sides tarnished the
other's reputations until everybody
involved looked quite bad except for
Stalin because he had kept quiet
trotsky's reputation as a military
leader was particularly damaged and he
had to resign as head of the Soviet
Armed Forces whilst all of this was
going on Stalin was making friends with
the other politburo members like the
editor of prafter Nikolai bakarin he
also made friends with the man actually
doing the day-to-day running of the USSR
Alexi rickov and this is where Trotsky
fell short Stalin was willing to concede
points to make friends and put gaining
power over any ideological Purity
whereas Trotsky would concede precisely
nothing and his staunch opposition to
the deeply held beliefs of his fellow
Communists did not win him any friends
when it was time for new internal
elections to the polyp Bureau Stalin's
new friends were able to band together
and got command of demoted whilst
bringing in more friends of Stalin this
spooked everyone else who suddenly
thought hey this Trotsky guy might not
be so bad after all as such New Alliance
the United opposition they opposed the
New Economic Policy wanted faster
industrialization a more interference in
foreign affairs to spread communism
these may or may not have been good
points but it didn't matter because
Stalin was in control of most of the
levers of power at this point and so he
just used the secret police to threaten
members of the United opposition into
silence he got Trotsky deselected and
soon afterwards he outlawed opposing the
politbura's policies Trotsky was then
exiled to the Kazakh region of the USSR
and was then kicked out of the country
in 1929 and so with Trotsky dealt with
Stalin was free to fully assert his
control over the party and subsequently
of the seven members of the poly Bureau
who served just after Lenin's death
Stalin purged most of them and
assassinated Trotsky in Mexico in 1940
leaving himself as the unparalleled
ruler of the USSR I hope you enjoyed
this episode with a special thanks to my
Patron James bizzinette Kelly moneymaker
call show wolf Sky Chappelle cartoon
Jerry lambdin Alex Schwinn Adam Stalter
Jordan Longley rod D Martin why in
hockey Marcus Arsenal Captain psydog
Marvin Castle Spencer Lightfoot Winston
caywood boogly Wiggly Daniel tobian
kamun Yoon Miss izet Gustav Swan Aaron
the white Anthony Beckett the mcwhopper
Maggie Paskowski Coppertone spinning
three plates she went in words about
books podcast and Charles the first